[Music]
good evening
uh thank you guys for uh coming out to
our less used venue but now we'll be
probably be seeing you here more often
in 2013 as many of you know the cowell
in fort mason and the herpst are both
closed for renovation for the rest of
the year
um
but we are very happy to be here at the
marines memorial
and um
as many of you know we start these talks
with what we call a long short a short
film that exemplifies long-term thinking
tonight's we also wanted to cross over
into
computing and mechanical computing
this one kind of is near and dear to my
heart as a designer and builder of a 10
000 year mechanical clock that has
astronomical dials uh my heart is warmed
by the fact that it might be found at
the bottom of the ocean
and that 2000 years later someone might
take x-rays of it and put it back
together and know what the heck we were
trying to do
this one happens to have been a
recreation of the antiquethera device
in lego
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
about
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
good evening i'm stuart brandt from the
long now foundation
i wonder if they could make that 500
feet high inside a mountain
and in fact
can we make a
10 000 year long now clock out of legos
whole marketing process that could
happen there
i'm wearing a jacket
[Applause]
in honor of our speaker
negropani is from the east coast where
they wear jackets
and when i arrived a little late he was
here he had no jacket he had left his
jacket in the green room in honor of the
west coast which doesn't wear jackets
so we'll both both wear jackets tonight
the peculiar thing about
[ __ ] potty well one of the peculiar
things about negropani
is that these
total east coast guy
right down to his toenails
and unlike every other east coast person
understands the west coast very well
and prac probably better than we do
and
that's why i wound up working at the
media lab back in 1987 having seen him
at the west coast in the 1984
first ted conference in monterey
and if there's a real dynamic east coast
west coast
that is fruitful instead of the usual
argument junk
it's because nicholas has been that kind
of amphibian
among many other kinds of amphibians
comfortable government you're
comfortable with corporations you come
full in the ivory tower
and
i think you'll be comfortable up here
talking about i'm not sure what nicholas
[ __ ] funny
[Applause]
i don't know
i don't consider myself east coast
i actually don't consider myself
anything
i
grew up without feeling an ounce of
nationalism
because i
went in different parts of the world and
actually grew up without
thinking that i belonged to a country
and i have three passports and i
just have never thought of nationalism
as something or parts of countries
and uh it may show itself in sort of
some of my remarks
stuart asked me to talk about the very
long term
and
don't know if i can quite do 10 000
years stuart but i i'll try and
uh go beyond some of the things i've
been doing recently and the way i'm
going to do it is
is is take a running start and talk a
little bit about the past
because
i get credit
sort of
unfairly
for
so-called predicting the future and i
didn't really predict the future i
extrapolated from what we were doing
uh in the lab and extrapolation's a lot
easier
so when somebody had to
read and collect and so on and and
predict that's a very different
art form and it's a very different uh
phenomenon so i
got the
sorry i've got to point this i've got
the pleasure
of extrapolating
and so being digital was actually a bit
old-fashioned some of the people who
read it in 95 said come on there's
nothing new in here it's what we're
already doing
and when i looked back when i thought
forward and
listened to stuart
i tried to find the one thing that sort
of characterized everything i'd done and
sort of the things
i think about and it really turned out
to be this difference between bits and
atoms and i might not have called it
that
uh 30 40 years ago but it really was
about the difference
and most people don't realize that the
word bits is is very new it's actually
1948 the word didn't exist before and it
was the concatenation of binary and
digit
people didn't
really it wasn't used in the language
and it's not as i say
particularly old
so
when we started at the media lab and
before the media lab
to to articulate it and to think about
it more clearly
i think you will find the end
some pretty startling
results when you don't think not just of
atoms but your atoms aren't in your
thinking about things and so i will try
to work up to that
i thought i would
go back to my very beginning
to to take a running start from that far
back
i was convinced at the age of 17 i would
be an artist
because i'd won all the art prizes at
school and and i had done things always
in art and always drawing and
going to museums as as a little child on
my own actually i think i went off to
museums at the age of seven and eight on
my own
but i made a mistake
in the sense that i did very well in
math too and
got an 800 in my math whatever it was
called s.a.t or the achievements and
went to the headmaster i was always very
ballsy about things like that i went to
the headmaster of the school and i said
you know i got
800 in my math and i love art and so
obviously i should go into architecture
because it's where the two are meat
and this headmaster of this private
school in connecticut
was very smart and he said something to
me that was extraordinary he said you
know
i like gray suits and i like pinstripe
suits but i hate gray pinstripe suits
and
that was so extraordinary
that i went to architecture school and i
in fact i did two degrees in
architecture before i realized that it
was the gray pinstripe suit
and that really the mix of the two
was computers and
my first job in life is on the screen
here it was sort of doing so this is 66
by the way
um highly influenced by
uh moshe
saftes architecture which had been for
the montreal
uh
world's fair habitat that you probably
know and by the way just out of pure
chance he's my neighbor now and perhaps
my dearest friend so sort of life comes
back in these these funny circles
but this was
you know multi-million dollar computer
driving this display in a room bigger
than this theater
um that sort of run all this stuff but
it was my first
you know effort in it i didn't really
think of
you know the fact that humans can't
experience bits and that you have to
display them but this was these were my
training wheels and literally running
around in the in the computer room
loading a tape running back they
actually let me use it alone this this
giant machine which is a little bit like
being in a machine shop alone you
shouldn't be allowed to do that
but uh it was probably dangerous but i
remember because i had whatever
45 or minutes or an hour a day of this
thing to myself and so you really ran to
get the stuff load physically loaded
onto things to get the most use out of
it and then i decided i would
do something this was my first uh
step into the art world with at a museum
in new york the jewish museum
and my so-called piece was again habitat
influence these little blocks were being
manipulated by a robot and the theory
god this was a weak and silly theory but
the theory was that the gerbils would
move the blocks with intention
and that that what the robot would do is
redo the bots the blocks so you would
see this evolving architecture
extraordinarily silly but um it it
really was a fun um and we we
anticipated all sorts of
of
problems but the one i didn't think of
was when this
mechanical arm came down
on a block and there was a gerbil
sitting on top
i don't know if you've had gerbils but
when you squeeze them it goes awfully
far and you get it didn't kill any
gerbils but you really get a lot of
gerbil on each side and almost nothing
in between so
we had animal
animal complaints
this was one of our very early projects
and you'll see why i'm trying to take a
running stock from the past because this
is uh
god this is
72 or something a 71 or somewhere 7173
and it was a pressure sensitive not just
touch sensitive but pressure sensitive
because your finger when it touched the
screen there's enough friction that you
could introduce forces laterally so that
that this person
is touching the screen and the length of
the arrow is how hard he's pushing in
that direction um it was i believe if it
wasn't it was very close to the world's
first touch sensitive display and people
thought that was stupid they wrote
stories about how touch was stupid and i
had these wonderful liners about how
one fingers are so wonderful you don't
have to pick them up that was one of my
sentences at the time um
and i thought you know really cool stuff
people said no you would dirty the
display
and i said no no you would be if the
display was dirty you'd be cleaning it
if it was clean you'd be dirtying it so
there'd be a steady state depending on
your finger
we did it early
again i still didn't think of turning of
bits into atoms but
it was this was now
mid 70s
the idea of that you
you know where things are spatially and
did a lot of
early work that i don't want to dwell on
except
i found a thing about this picture of
the calculator
again people
wrote things about you know only at mit
would there be the arrogance to display
a calculator on this you know million
dollar system and it'd be on the screen
and you touch it and so on how stupid
that was well i guess in one context it
was stupid
um
i don't want to spend too much time on
this stuff but there's at least one
person in this audience mike neymar whom
i saw earlier out of the corner of my
eye who will remember this project which
was an aspen movie map
um
it almost
won the proxmyer award are there people
in this room that remember the golden
fleece award
god i wanted to win it so badly and
never won it
i was nominated two or three times
apparently but this was one that almost
made it it almost won the prox
golden fleece award
because it was using military money to
document um the streets in all
directions and
i thought this was cute somebody sent me
those pictures
that is 78
car and that's the google one that does
it today
um
i haven't asked google for royalties but
it's
it's uh goes way back
and then to start having displays and
gestures and this was kind of the
beginning the beginning of the media lab
now in parallel with that and this leads
into a story
uh
that i think you'll find if you don't
know about it rather compelling in 1982
seymour papert and i started an
experiment that was funded by
opec at the time that started as opec
funding you may remember there was a man
named sheikh yamani he was the bad guy
but he funded us to work
in paris
at something that started and then
collapsed soon soon after but we did get
a start in the use of computers in
the developing countries
for learning and
seymour
whom i had known already for about 14
years
wrote
a lot of very important papers and i
know there are people in this room who
who knew him no i should say
knew him because he's alive but not
alive but he's
you know he does communicate with some
people
at any rate um
seymour wrote a paper which was the
introduction to warren mcculloch's book
called you can't think about thinking
unless you think about thinking about
something now if that's not a brilliant
title i don't i really
and he was that kind of person now what
seymour
taught me
very early on long before the paris
experiment
was the fact that computer programming
was a way to think about thinking and
that
debugging programs was pretty close
approximation to learning about learning
and
whether that goes
you know a lot further
is not 100 percent clear because
constructionism has fallen off the table
it has truly um
really succumbed to instructionism where
all of these moocs and khan academy and
all of that
the moocs are okay but
it's
the khan academy stuff
saul is a wonderful person but it's the
most misguided stuff i've seen in a long
time and it's sucking the air out of the
room which is also a rather interesting
phenomenon
winding up a little bit
by chance i was able
many years later almost 20 years later
to do some of this work
in cambodia
and the period in between was when
my job was
was the media lab and
the
main part of my job and the media lab
was to raise money and to raise as much
of it as possible and did a reasonable
job over the period
but in parallel did a few things outside
of mit one of was right here
i don't know if lewis and his kids are
in the audience but starting wired
magazine with them was one of the
highlights of my life
and
also a little bit later working in
cambodia had enormous influence and what
happened with the cambodian stuff after
doing the media lab
i sort of said to myself it's my turn
and
about seven years ago
uh we brought in a new director to the
media lab
and i went off and and did one laptop
per child and i don't again want to
spend too much time on that though it
leads to
to the reason i'm talking today one
laptop per child was a non-profit and
that was very very important because
there's such an important difference
between
a market and a mission
and when people talk about
investing in
something that's going to be profit
making but
do good in some way that's fine but you
know be a non-profit it's uh it's a much
clearer uh phenomenon and it lets you
have partners i'm not trying to show a
picture of myself with kofi annan but
as much as that you can have a partner
like that you can have the un as a
partner
and he turns out
mary lou jepson's in the audience um
she will remember this because she was
there she was at she actually she was
probably the shouldn't have cut you out
of the photograph you were probably the
next seat over uh to the right or left
um but uh
this was the i think i have a picture of
the yes i do
um this
very silly laptop
design
but it was very photogenic and it cast
all the right metaphors now you never
you don't want to put a crank on the
side of a laptop and mary lou can
explain to you why but what was
interesting is that when kofi annan is
on stage it fills the room with cameras
and i i wouldn't be saying this if it
wasn't the truth because i have somebody
in the room that was there but
one of the people one of the camera
people or reporters in the audience
yelled out kofi annan and nicholas
negroponte crank your laptops
so we close the laptops put you know and
then we start cranking
and
the handle falls off in his hand these
are engineering models
and the hand the crank the handle falls
off and he doesn't blink he continues
moving his hand
as if it hadn't fallen off
and holding it with this little silly
yellow thing standing in midair and i
don't think anybody knew
okay
and what's extraordinary is most people
go you know they would sort of think
what's happened i broke it or something
no he's as cool as a cucumber
or i'm cranking that thing
so that's that's you all know this thing
and there it is some of the pictures
well
this this project got a disproportionate
amount of bad press but
uh
about two years ago
a very dear friend of mine
took the piece that was
more sort of laptop oriented and has
been running it and i asked myself a
very specific question
which i'll get to and then
get to some of the the points quicker
what happens when there are no schools
and the reason that's interesting at
least was interesting to me and still is
but two years ago i latched on to it
was that
the official number today is 61 million
children don't go to first grade
basically
um
and
first of all it's a very interesting
because you know where does that number
come from because if a child is six
and doesn't go to first grade
next year that child is seven
you still count the child and now
there's a new child come into the system
so the child is now seven who's been
counted last year and this year um and
then that child becomes eight
do you still count the child and so
depending where you draw the line you
can get
i mean if you drew the line at 25 you'd
get really high numbers so you back off
and i can find a a grade level where you
would come out at 60 or 61 but i think
your i think the numbers are higher so
let me use since i love round numbers
let me use 100 million
um there are 100 million kids who don't
go to school
most of them
don't go to school because there isn't
one not because they're truants
or the parents have forced them to work
in the field it's because there really
isn't a school and that means walking
distance
that means at least a school you can get
to so
if there's a school 10 miles away
for primary school that that doesn't
that doesn't help you
and so when we asked that question we
were already working on tablets
we decide what could we could we run an
experiment and the experiment
uh is is really very simple the
experiment is the question can a child
learn to read
on his or her own
and
it's this reason the question
was so simple to frame uh is that
there's this cusp where you learn to
read
and then you read to learn now it's not
a peak it's not a sharp point but it
tends to happen in second or third grade
uh typically in this country
um
and that's fine so there's there's that
cusp and so if you can get over the cusp
then you are extremely advantaged and
the brain has
evolved over you pick a number a million
years and the period of evolution we
have learned how to talk um and other
things talk and walk where the brain
does that quite naturally but reading is
only
something like 3500
years old so the brain really doesn't do
it naturally so you have to spend some
time quote learning it the question is
how much of that can be on your own how
much of it if any can be more like
talking uh and more like some of these
things we do
uh by interacting with the world and so
we started this experiment um
we picked two
two villages in ethiopia
and we picked ethiopia because we knew
the country the head of state had been a
great fan of one laptop per child so the
minister was a fan and the governor was
a fan and everybody down the line uh
sort of that it was kind of contagious
and it was easy to work there and there
it happens to be
proportion in terms of percentage of
kids either the highest or second
highest depending on who you ask
in the world it's not the highest
absolute numbers that turns out to be
nigeria but ethiopia in terms of
ethiopia and afghanistan compete with
each other to have the highest
percentage of kids
who are illiterate and don't go to
school so it was a reasonable place to
work
and what we did is we loaded
the tablets with very mediocre material
i don't want for a moment for anybody to
think that that this is beautifully
crafted software that
uh
quote teaches you anything it's just
there's there's just lots of it there
are
400 apps
on this tablet and
the apps are in four categories they're
they're games that are conspicuously
letter games and phonemic phonemes
they're movies that are kids movies
subtitled almost always
and this by the way is all english it's
so the kids have to learn a language
that isn't spoken as well as reading and
writing it
and then their cartoons and theirs their
books lots of books
so
these were dropped off uh in the village
without any instructions
uh with no humans um a
a solar panel was delivered
uh the day before and what adult was
shown
how to
how to sort of run it now i've i've been
known to say that they hadn't seen words
in the village
we discovered that's not a hundred
percent true there's some labels on kids
clothing um and some
recently there might have been some
bottles with labels on them but
basically it's nobody none of the adults
are literate uh
the children have
certainly not seen
words and books and magazines
so we dropped these off
and
the tablets are hot in the sense that
they record everything the kids do
and once a week
the peop the locals who are working with
us go into the village
and swap sim cards basically put in a
new sim card and take out the old one
because the old one has been recording
every touch
photographing
listening recording
all of it irb
approved and cleared um
for those of you who are concerned about
that sort of thing
uh
what's important at least was important
to me in the beginning
was that in two and a half minutes the
first kid
uh figured out
a there was something in the box and b
there was an on off switch and that
turned on the switch and apparently when
the kid did it he sort of yelled out i
am the lion and that's that's
and he was apparently the
physically i won't say physically
disabled but
was really a very uh
not the fastest and most active and the
most forward kid in the village at all
in fact so much so
uh at one point they
thought of not even counting him in the
counts they're trying to leave as many
tablets as there were kids in the
village
so
two and a half minutes to turn it on
within five days they were using 50 apps
per child per day
and within two weeks they were singing
abc songs and within five months they
hacked android
now
now
now people there have been people who
say well what does he mean hacked
android did he got the kids go into some
utility and flip a switch no they didn't
they actually hacked android because
our team rightly or wrongly
had disabled the camera
because we wanted to sort of use it to
take pictures we didn't want it to be
used
probably or definitely a mistake and the
kids
found a way to hack around that and it's
a little bit more than turning on a
switch
the degree to which it's generating code
or they had to actually type some things
as you know people can fuss over that
but there really was uh some some major
effort i couldn't do it that's
i don't know if that's
now let me just do one say one last
thing about this and then go on to the
extrapolation part
um this is perhaps the best
image i have
uh and
the kit on the right it's not a hundred
percent clear what he's doing um whether
he's bored or whether he's actually
running the class
but
it's
what interests me more are the five kids
uh in between because
the if you look at the kid on on your
left
um
is using the other kids tablet and the
other kids using the other kids tablet
and talk about collaboration
and
all five are running different apps
which is which is pretty interesting as
well
with one laptop per child we always went
through schools or almost always went
through schools and you know the teacher
would say well now we're all going to do
this and and so that there was a
synchrony a synchronous sort of use that
certainly was not happening uh in this
village now we made a mistake
um we made a mistake that i made a
mistake
and that was as i named the villagers uh
in a paper i gave out the name i said
this village and that not even thinking
what would happen and now the kids in
those villages give press conferences
and and this is a press conference this
kid is showing a reporter um that she
can write words and so on and so forth
so it's been to say the least
contaminated but in the past month
the person who is part of the team
somebody named marianne wolff who's at
tufts university and really is one of
the world's authority on how the brain
learns
learns to read
went to the village and has come back
you know just startled because the kids
are doing what she calls
cautiously but she still calls it
nonetheless the precursors of reading
because they're sight words and they can
phonemic they can pronounce things out
and they were given tests and they could
sound out words
that they didn't know and that was
pretty impressive so on the force of
that
uh
my life changed about a month ago
in the sense that i'm now
chairing uh the x prize where the prize
went up last week it's now 15 million
dollars
to basically reenact this and do it at
scale and do the technology that would
be much more serious than what we did
which was
you know scrambled together
applications so
that's what we're doing and now how do
we go forward
and what are some of the things that you
know
at least the short long now and as i
tried to think of it and
may or may not
come to things that you haven't thought
of this one you have and that is that
the the world of silicon and biology
and whether it's the synthetic and the
natural have
have been
so we always think of them as different
things are inanimate inanimate and
uh so
i think what the future holds and it's
probably you won't have to go that far
out i mean 100 years will
will be actually a long time it will be
sooner than that is that there will be
no difference anymore there'll be no
difference between the synthetic and the
natural and the silicon and the biology
they will all just come together it
won't be a fried egg it'll be an omelet
and the the fried egg nature of the
world which is with the world our
parents knew which had crisp edges
around things that were yellow and white
by metaphor at least
will no longer be that way and it's
happening in in a variety in lots of
different ways actually and i used you
know i want to bring a few
examples because i was
recently introduced
um
to to a couple of concepts that blew me
away i had not thought
of the fact uh
that and let's say this is an existing
company called
by the way it's called modern meadow i
think it's modern meadow or modern
meadows
and they actually are printing uh meat
and they're printing the tissue too so
that you really basically walk off with
a hamburger or a steak
and
i thought wow that's pretty interesting
if you can print meat you can print
creatures
uh god that starts to ch all this stuff
we're kind of looking at
printing
uh physical objects and we think it's
it's you know 3d printing is so advanced
but
my god if we start
eating the stuff we print and it walks
off the page
after it's been printed
that's pretty different
and
it it the meat one was so convincing
because
it uses only one percent of the water
and half a percent of the land and you
know to make it which is kind of nice
but also you don't have to print the
parts that you're not going to eat you
only have to print
you know the filet if that's what you're
interested in you don't need to print
the hooves and the ears and some people
like pig ears and maybe you make glue
out of other things but now you can just
print the pieces you want and i thought
that's that's pretty
pretty incredible and i started to to
think about
those things and thought
wow this is really a new bits and atoms
story
this isn't transmitting a 3d object and
making it it's starting to transmit
things that i thought of as natural or
coming uh from the environment so that
that i think you know tiptoes on to the
the world of uh you know a very
seriously different world of the future
um
so i then said and this is where i'm
getting
close to the punch line
is what does adam's thinking
you know lead you to now newspaper
newspapers kind of that's obvious but
most people don't
pay attention to the fact that newspaper
has the word paper in it
uh and there are only apparently two
languages that do that now if somebody
can think of others that would be great
but the english and apparently chinese
does it too uses uh the
you know the the
icon for paper in the in the word
newspaper
so that's easy
telecom pricing is less obvious
but
it took me
a little bit of time to figure out that
the energy required to move something is
such that if it's heavier and you're
going a longer distance you're going to
charge more okay that's simple
and so if you're going to mail a feather
or you know a long distance or carry an
anvil a short distance it might cost the
same and that you could you know build
your entire model around that which is
what the phone company did if you called
a long distance uh you paid more and if
you shipping lots of bits
you would pay more
which
is really comes from the world of atoms
and
it turns out that the
number of bits that you transmit
is
almost
inconsequential
to the meaning or the time you spend
with it
uh a book
for those of you who have written them
and those of you who read them uh uh
you know a normal novel is a million
bits
sorry it's a million bytes sorry off by
eight but i caught that one um but it's
a million bytes now a million bytes
is is not that much you know you have a
good modern camera with a good
sensor when you click it you're you're
you're capturing a million bytes
so
and then video you know if it's high
resolution and you're trying it's it's
it's enormous the number of it's
and
one of the things about the internet
and the people who were thinking about
it early on
and you had told them that netflix is
going to be 35
of the internet bandwidth in this year
2013 on sunday afternoons
they would have laughed i mean
but that's actually what it is
and it's because it uses so many bits
and it's very very
bit hungry so tell a price
sorry telecom pricing sort of came from
the world of atoms and in some sense the
world of you know wealth does too people
acquire things they're kind of physical
there's a lot of atoms thinking yes
there's wealth and intellectual wealth
and all sorts of other forms but
it is very very rooted uh in atoms
especially some of the basic things like
drinking water and clothes and you know
a roof over your head
so
that's the the
sort of some of the obvious ones sort of
the less obvious ones are the ones that
i think are
the ones that
maybe will be in conversation when
stuart and i talk or and questions you
ask but i think the one that is is the
serious one going back to my very first
comment is countries
countries come from the world of atoms
and i think
that
nationalism is the biggest disease on
the planet
and
what do countries come from when they
come from something that you can
actually walk around the edge
um there's a body of water there's a
mountain
range um and then it's what's inside
what's outside
uh and because
communications
uh was so poor that you would have all
of these languages that would grow up
sometimes you'd have a language that was
totally different on the other side of
the mountain
and
certainly across bodies of water now
the problem with countries is they're
too big
usually too big to be
uh local and they're too small to to be
global
and the granularity of countries is kind
of exactly the wrong size
um in fact it couldn't be worse
and
then we go with it then we start talking
about competitiveness national
competitiveness and that that actually
uh is revolting that is that really is
obscene because
we are going to worry about
competitiveness
um
in massachusetts we're not going to
worry about connecticut and we're
actually not even going to worry about
california but you just go a little
further and you cross some boundary and
suddenly we it's there's uh what does it
mean to compete even on physical things
like growing tomatoes and and it's not
just intellectual
so i think that that
probably the least obvious uh example of
what comes from the world of atoms is
countries and
i don't know how to get rid of them
because
the
global organization and i've got to be a
little careful here but
you know the united nations the world
bank
organizations like that
are near useless um partly because of
their own
operations but something like the world
bank is based on countries countries are
donors and recipients and that make
requests and again it's all if you build
a road in africa that goes from north to
south through nine countries you're
dealing with nine different divisions in
the bank or in the united nations
there's no concept of really road or
concept of education and and languages
fall out of that
languages
people are constantly saying to me well
how can you give an x prize to learn how
to read and write english
around the world well the answer is is
real simple
and it's it's not the new colonialism uh
the answer is it's it's the new
globalism and that
any head of state whom you ask will ask
that their kids learn english at least
as a second language and in quite a few
countries it's the first language even
though it's not spoken in the villages
you go to a country like sierra leone
and the kids in first grade learn how to
read and write english even though it's
not spoken in the village
and so this is not something that that
that i invented or that it's happening
just because of the tablet experiment
it's something that is in fact happening
now project out if it's 10 000 years
it's easy first of all there'll be
nobody to collect the bets but it's easy
to bet on
on there being one language
um people
you know sometimes well maybe there'll
be two maybe chinese in english or
chinese and the latin alphabet won't
merge but i think they will and uh it's
certainly we've got ten thousand years
that they they can they can they will
merge uh so you know will we speak one
language yes will we write one language
and read yeah i think so so that's sort
of
perhaps the extreme and
i think i have no this is my la that was
my last slide
so that may be
a hint oh i guess this is actually cute
in the sense that it was my first slide
on the screen
um
i found this see if this is a postcard
that was made in france
uh in i think 1917
as to what education would be in the
year 2000 and
i thought that was an extraordinary
image
and
there's a piece of me that wants to do
that because i was dyslexic uh still am
and reading is is a challenge but then
my wife who founded and run the boston
runs the boston book festival see
clearly i'm compensating um
she gets the new york review of books
and i don't know how many of you look at
that regularly or once in a blue moon
the books that are advertised have these
extra they all have extraordinary covers
cover design in the book world has
skyrocketed
books are really have in general very
very nice covers and so i look at the
books in the boston and sorry in the new
york review of books that are advertised
on the various pages the various presses
and i'm i'm just awestruck by a how good
that but of course in the process i read
the title and i say wow i'd like to read
that book and i look at them i say boy
in one issue they're about
500 books that i would love to read
maybe not that many maybe it's 200 but
it's it's a lot of books and
you know maybe this is the way to do it
uh is to sort of get it
so i think stuart we're on if wherever
you're sitting
i don't know if i came in on time or off
time but if it's too short we'll make up
for it and questions thank you very much
uh you're glided by something
fundamental fancy okay
um only one well
[Music]
so much seemed to rotate on it i want to
be sure what was there that it sounded
like it was constructionism versus
instructionism or something like that
yeah
unpack a little
oh
any learning by discovery
fits constructionism
but the more pure people would argue
that it includes making
you can't just discover without making
something
it's so
that world is is
maybe simply stated as the learning by
doing
the instructionist world is learning by
being told and whether it's told
this way or
being told by reading or some other
you know
so-called multimedia experience
that's the instructionism side and i'm
always fascinated by the fact that
knowing and learning are
kind of confused
and that because our system tests you on
what you know
not on your ability to learn it's
flawed it's a faulty system
can you test for ability to learn or for
required ability to learn i think the
test for the ability to learn is
generally considered
the ability to be a creative
mind and a creative but to look at
problems differently to
to
basically see things
marvin would always say this from more
than one point of view
and
that's
you know a very good test
road learning
and i'm being very sort of simplistic
here
is the easiest and i think it's
pretty deadly they're actually people
who
think
that the chinese and the koreans have a
better education system it's
mind-boggling it's just
stunning
who has a better education system from
your standpoint
the well-known one the country that gets
credit all the time is finland
and
the scandinavian countries in general
get a get a pretty good
but
you know the problem with
education in this country
uh is is in some sense separate from the
institution of schools
it's a lot of other things that are
happening and the fact that it's age
segregated
that it's
run on real estate taxes by and large
and
you know this test stuff teaching to
test my god we pay teachers
in accordance to test results
you would pay them in accordance with
what how would you know
the right thing is happening
i certainly wouldn't do it by
test scores um i mean what you do with
one laptops is basically you attract
you watch their little fingers at work
yeah
i would
spend time with the kids have
one of the things that
is so clear when you go into a classroom
and you
you know you meet
a few children
you have to test them you know pretty
quickly what's going on
and i was fascinated in the
you know there are about three million a
little less than three million laptops
out there now
our are our laptops and one of the most
surprising results is how much teachers
like them
and everybody thought teachers would
hate them and teachers often don't like
them
until they get them
i remember when that happened with
calculators back when remember those
days
it doesn't let the pocket calculator in
the math class it's cheating
and it was considered cheating yeah and
then the teachers discovered actually
made math easy instead of impossible
and enjoyable instead of a big pain
so alexander rose has a version of
kevin says there's seven versions to
this question
khan academy is just misguided can you
elaborate on a more useful way to do
online education
well
khan academy's
problem is the age group and even khan
academy skews upward and thinks in terms
of middle school and high school
and
arguably the instructionist approach
makes more and more sense as you you you
get older and older you could argue that
that that's that's where it it's not
in the first five or six years of school
we all remember
great teachers in our lives great
teachers when we were young
but they were great not because they
knew a subject you didn't like your
history teacher because he or she knew
history
they knew you
and they got you excited and they got
the class excited and and it wasn't
about the transmission of a
body of knowledge you need to test
it was
your
creativity and energy that was being
amplified by somebody who who got you
interested so the first
part is the
first few years just like the first five
years before you even go to school it's
not so much the acquisition of
bodies of knowledge it's more the
acquisition of
the ability to acquire the stuff now
part of the khan academy theory or that
anyway the practice that emerged is that
the teachers instead of
quote instructing
basically lecturing passive kids that
sort of happens at home
on the computer and what the teachers
are now doing is kind of helping the
kids and the kids helping each other
with quote homework which does sound
like your kind of thing
very much um khan academy
has done two things splendidly
um
one
it's a non-profit which i think is
really something very important and
people
don't keep in mind enough
um
the second is that they participated in
they didn't invent but they participated
in so-called flipping the classroom
where you
do stuff which is what you're talking
about but then there are three things
that are so wrong it kind of annihilates
the first two
um
one
and i've talked to saul about this
he seems to think that he and a small
number of people can make all the
material
that's changing a little bit but hello
that
that doesn't make sense
the second
is that
the minimalism
of graphics
is not
to be confused with low production
values
okay i'm very happy to have
minimalist graphics but
it's low production values that he's
actually gone and the third thing and
this i don't know why we're ranting on
saul but the third thing which is the
worst
is there's this belief
you can become a quick study
and read a book on chile after the
allende government
and then do
a program on it
or a program on communist he happens to
know about algebra so that worked
okay and then
you know bill gates and others picked up
on but you know then doing something on
a subject
it's not that it's hard versus soft it's
it's a subject that you know they're
people who've spent their lives maybe
not studying chile after the agenda
government but studying communism or
subject like that
and it's it's not something you can
become a quick study and do an hour so
those three things seem so
so flagrantly wrong that uh
i'm surprised that it's gotten the
traction but it has obviously because
flipping the classroom is a very good
idea because he's a splendid person
which is also important you've said a
couple times now of kind of the
vehemence that uh
non-profits are amazing and wonderful
and
[Music]
you put it sort of market versus mission
see a little more
was mit a non-profit i forget yes of
course
yes
and
yeah and all of its money comes from
that's interest businesses
uh
and mit i mean you know stanford and
east coast west coast
frederick turman learned at mit how to
hook companies to a university and
forget the ivory tower and bring in the
money and then put out the
hewlett packards and silicon valley was
invented basically at mit and then came
through stanford
so
uh that nonprofit
works best when it's really
pretty
well funded by for-profits seems like
but it sounds like
yeah yeah
i mean
you're picking one that happens to
you know
you even had to ask if it was a
non-profit
well i remember it's a corporation it
makes a big deal about that yeah um
i think you you have to let me phrase it
differently and and
i wake up in the morning and i ask
myself one question
will normal market forces do what i'm
doing
and if the answer is yes
then stop doing it i shouldn't do it
bill gates has been doing that same
analysis did he get it from you or you
guys converge
anyway um
but
the
the problem with non-profits and i'll
talk about big ones including the gates
foundation but just in general
ngos
are so badly run
people say well it's got to be a
business because then it'll be well run
and if it's not a business it won't be
well run but rubbish
you can be business like and run a
non-profit very well
and one shouldn't confuse
business like with being a business
now the problem with scale especially
the non-profits who give money
and i'll include i'll take the mcarthur
foundation i'll pick on the macarthur
foundation um
by the way jerry wiesner who was
president of mit went to see macarthur
uh when
in florida he lived in florida and
macarthur said to him young man
what would you do with a hundred million
dollars
and jerry very foolishly didn't do too
many foolish things
um
in his life but this was foolish he said
to macarthur um
let me think about it and get back to
you
[Music]
and he comes back to mit and macarthur
dies
okay
so
big mistake
big mistake
[Laughter]
but he was on the macarthur board now
the macarthur does this extraordinary
genius grants thing
which whatever it's called that there's
a proper name for it um
whatever but it's it's it's i think it's
kind of interesting everybody knows
about it everything in the street knows
about everything this room knows about
then they do other things
okay which you don't know about
particularly i mean if you do you're
kind of an outlier and you might have
you know heard of one or two things now
why is that the case
the case is because you have program
directors
and program directors have directors and
programs and suddenly you have this
whole institution you've got to give
them all a little bit of money to manage
and this gets in and finally you you'll
find that the number of program
directors i'm not you saying whether
they're good or bad you just take the
number of programmers and divide divided
into the leftover money
it's like corporate social
responsibility which is a really bad
idea and corporate social responsibility
suffers from the same thing i was on the
motorola board and we had 300 million
dollars in the foundation
and i thought wow that's pretty
interesting that can make an impact no
their motorbike was in 570 countries and
each one got a little piece and then
there were four divisions you divided
that by four and then there were
different people and they all that and
so it was all these little tiny
little twenty thousand thirty thousand
dollar grants which has no traction no
critical mass and it just dissipates
and so that's another problem which
happens with the big foundation
i believe there are a thousand
professionals at the gates foundation
so you like small nonprofits
i like big non-profits with a small
number of people
now
let me ask you a question yeah
[Applause]
in the six years of the one laptop per
child
how much money was involved
over six years uh
six six years that's all well that was
the time that i was about seven if you
want to add a year um
less than 10 million more than four
okay it was a billion a billion dollars
a billion dollars
i'm off by how many orders
okay and the reason was obedient is you
first of all take 3 million and multiply
it by an average of 200 you get to 600
million right there
so that was you guys slipping on your
message
the rest was it wasn't coming through
this little group in cambridge you had
150 people working in uruguay
okay on one laptop per child it was
called plan cebal
150 people still 150 people times
their salaries large or small times six
years
times all the other stuff
it added up to a billion
let me ask you a question about the one
laptop which
puzzles me because i run into various
forms of it which is the the
very public troll behavior that emerged
uh so you put out one laptop or child
here's an acropony you know
spending years of his life and
uh trying to get education to the world
and a lot of people are going yeah it
won't work blab who does he think he is
the wrong theory wrong tech
what the hell is that all about what is
this
troll thing that gets loose
well
we won't talk about the parts where they
were right okay let's leave that out
is there a little piece
um
the
we can't to me the most surprising
you know i look back you say what
surprises you the most
what surprises me the most
was
the degree to which
commercial interests would go
to sort of sabotage things
i thought i had a mother teresa shield
around me
and it just isn't so they saw this
competition or what or they were
cheating by being
it's
stuart it's it's it's things like
you know having a beach head or that
i remember when hewlett-packard
when i was a student hewler tektronix
and hewlett-packard actually mostly
tektronix
would give mit oscilloscopes each year
thousands of oscilloscopes gifts of
oscilloscopes
and that's because every mit student it
was tektronix actually
learned how to use an oscilloscope with
a tektronix oscilloscope so it was the
self-interest and the sort of the beach
head that they got was very important so
it's
partly that
and a lot of other things i mean it's
so i'm reminded
this is a bad subject i just came from
boston and we don't know what really
created the uh
you know the who who created the bombs
or the motive or anything
but
one of the things
that changed
terrorism worldwide
was
when somebody was willing to give up
their life
and so if you strap bombs on yourself
and you walk that's pretty cool suicide
bombers were new that was a real
real inflection point
and i remember telling a couple
of
companies
who will remain nameless um
i said you know
i'm not earning a salary never earned a
penny
my career is
not dependent on one laptop per child
i don't care what anybody says i'm not
trying to protect her reputation i said
i'm like a suicide bomber
there's nothing you can do that's great
and they inspire each other don't they
there's a lot of copycat suicide bombers
out there
kevin kelly asks a question in the new
globalization new globalism will
diversity increase or will what
diversity diversity increase or will it
converge as language and currency well i
think this is sort of a granularity
question if you're saying that
nations are wrong
wrong size they're too small to be
global and too
big to be local
um so as some of this stuff goes global
does that mean a whole lot of other
stuff goes goes
local um
i guess
let me talk about diversity because
one of my favorite examples
and even if you don't you you eliminate
racial diversity and you just you just
look at the uk at england
and it's a country
that has this enormous respect not just
tolerance but respect for idiosyncrasies
have you ever met a non-idiosyncratic
englishman
or english woman
no right the diversity is paul wall
pretty much yeah but i mean the
the diversity and attitudes and so on is
kind of pretty high
it
even if
if you look at different parts of the
world
it's
it's i don't think diversity is going to
go down
in in
in the local sense i think it'll go up
not down
now maybe
you'd be better place to answer this
maybe genetically we will evolve into a
single race and intermarriage and the
genes you know modern meadow is going to
take us the opposite way we'll be
printing all kinds of one horde and
one-eyed flying purple people eaters
and and marrying them
maybe
r r has a question the new identity is
said to be a cohabitation of the real
and the virtual your bits in your atoms
isn't the real being run out of a town
by the virtual
oh
um
well the reel isn't being run out of
town because
that's all you can interact with you
can't enter you've it's got to the
virtual has to be transformed into
something you can see touch eat
whatever so
at least the real has
the interface um
interface meeting
but
i don't
i don't think the quality of life
is driven a lot by the the real not the
virtual um
and i think no it's not being run out of
town
uh
let me add to the question louis
rossetto that was just handed to me by
kevin oh god that's dangerous
louis says it used to be about adam's
becoming bits uh
this lecture was titled beyond digital
does that mean that bits are becoming
adamus after all we really do live in
the material world time for reappraisal
of the physical which it sounds like
you're working up on yeah
yeah
i had to you know it's one of these
things where stuart asks you to speak
and then says what you know what are you
going to talk about i don't know and
give it a title i thought beyond digital
was actually pretty good and then i
said jesus how am i going to live up to
that
but i i think the
the physical world is
you know is where the quality of life is
in many ways and then
the virtual world the
connection part
first of all physical things will be
connected to all other physical things
so
you know are they real are they virtual
how much of the behavior of the thing
comes from its connectivity how much is
happening in the thing how much it just
those boundaries will will start to
disappear
but
i find for instance the connectedness of
people
rather thrilling the idea of alone
together
sherry turkles beautiful title i mean
the title is fantastic
and i hope it gets used in the language
but i don't i i don't buy into that i
think you know the being connected
is is is quite extraordinary and
i found occasion
where in the middle of a dinner i
actually did send a message or receive a
message
and so yes the caricature of four young
kids sitting at a table all doing sms
with people not at the table
is is a caricature but
you know those of you who remember laser
printers when they were first introduced
god the stuff that came out of those was
was complete crap people changed fonts
and had big ones and shadow ones and
depths and things and it was a disaster
area it's set up everywhere are you and
alan kay marveling oh my god the world
is learning about kerning
a good thing to learn about but you you
know
stick to one font you know
you know and
preferably without serifs
well by now you probably have a theory
of how long it takes to go through the
that period of junk for the new medium
it's it's not clear how how long it
takes because there's always people that
have to re you know
go back through it again and
it's not just that society learns you
you find everybody that gets you know a
really large palette of anything is
going to start
um using it at first it's a little bit
like the first time you have a video
camera you're going to keep panning and
zooming this thing and then as you kind
of get used to it you'll sort of realize
that it's it's it's a medium where you
don't just want to keep panning and
zooming and changing
that there's
you can use it much more astutely
i remember when one of the mit students
sort of lashed a television camera onto
his body and went around living that way
and we all thought that was pretty
grotesque
and
yeah here it comes that that's seemingly
the way we'll all be with our glass or
whatever
um
yeah but the the and you always want the
people who are the precursors of it to
do that kind of stuff and if you know
anybody doing that kind of stuff send
them to the media lab that's where they
should be that's what we'd really like
to be the place where that happens now
then whether it
rolls out in the same way look how long
it took
for it to come to things like the google
glasses and and so on it's taken you
know a long time but
how's media lab doing this many years
later
look the media lab
did
the most incredible
piece of work it's done at least in a
decade and that is to hire joey ito all
right
okay
[Applause]
worth mentioning right i mean
well
the fact that he was timothy leary's
godson we left off
he didn't know that he didn't know that
piece
but he for those of you who don't know
him um at the time he's 44 years old and
uh
japanese he's 44 years old and he's a
dropout and
i have
gone back to the lab whatever that means
neither i nor mit completely no but one
of the things is that i'm involved with
hiring new faculty and i've interviewed
lots of faculty
candidates
and almost everyone has said that
they're interested in the faculty
position because of joey ito and if we
had the courage
and the aca in our academic institution
to hire a dropout
uh that that was the place they wanted
to be and i thought that's just splendid
okay courage and everything how's it
playing out what's actually happening in
the lab that joey's enabled
i what what's happening is
there's a real shift
uh away from objects to networks it's
happening it's a real shift um
into sort of
what's it's it's he's much more bottoms
up i was much more top down maybe that
goes with the suit uh you know
he's really much more
uh listening he listens i think this is
an error he listens to the students and
that's not we don't completely agree on
that
but
yeah why would you ever listen to the
students you know they're only there for
three or four years so they could by
definition have a very small view but
but in
the place is different it's changing
it's changing
very very quickly
i remember there were going to be
imitation media labs all over the place
is that worked out
there will never be an imitation um and
i'll tell you why it's not arrogance
it's
and again this is a it's it was a it was
very much luck
if you look at the constituent parts
what made up the media lab in the
beginning
i happened to be the academic head at
the time of
film department
photography
graphic design
computer animation
and even graduate music no code so those
were sort of already
part of the
band that was going to be
put together
and then i went to the then provost and
said
because seymour papert was in the
dsra division of study and research and
education
and i went to the provost and i said you
know i'd
like to include seymour pepper
and he said bless your heart
oh bless your heart and
you take them off my hands
and
i said we'd like to include marvin
ah and it was a cello de escelo de
refuse in the real sense
and the mit did not have an art school
did not have an ed school did not have a
journalism school did not have you go
down the list and then every other
potential place where it could have
existed
had some of those parts
so if you tried to do it someplace else
try to do it at
invent berkeley i believe there's a
journalism school and you try to do it
at usc and there's a film school and you
try and do it at harvard and there's the
carpenter center and there's
ed you know the ed school and then you
try so
the piece that was so magical is that
it's frictionless
absolutely frictionless nobody
the only friction you got was people
thought it was an opportunity cost but
what opportunity cost
we had sort of basically gathered
together the refuse and put ourselves in
a building
and so arguably the cost of the building
could have been
put for something else but that's bloody
expensive building you know the time it
wasn't so expensive
whatever 26 million dollars inspired me
to write a book about how terrible it
was
compared to building 20 across the way
yeah
well this raises a question in
embarrassing and there's there's a lot
of long now members hearing help us
think about this which has to do with
the question of
and uh we get invitations to you know
can we do long now in canada can we do
long now in london can we do long now
and you
saw no end of we would like to do media
lab in singapore we would like to do a
media lab in ireland when all these
friends did it five times or something
five failures
spell it out what happened why why do
franchises of these kinds of things fail
because
for some reason i'm a slow learner for
some reason
you forget how important the culture
around you is
whether it's the risk-taking
nature of the united states whether it's
the
willingness i remember when i wrote
lewis will remember there was one of my
first articles for wired
was called why europe
is so unwired
and
it went down the bullets which relate to
why you know media lab was happening
there in boston not in europe
and my father
my both my parents were alive and both
of them were
sort of hyper europeans i forgot if you
met them
they didn't they were they were brothers
but not your parents hyper european i
mean my father spoke eight languages if
you
played trivial pursuit with him he
corrected the cards
and the relationship with your
parents
was again in those days more formal than
mine even slightly more formal and i had
written this wired story as to why
europe was so unwired
and
my father was
i was visiting them in switzerland
over christmas and he said he didn't
like the story because it wasn't correct
and so i said well
let's discuss it after dinner i figured
we wouldn't try and do it at dinner and
let's go down the points
and
the first one was about
centralism
and he said whoa we're really
decentralists and you know it says you
don't argue with your father so i go to
the next point next point was risk
capital and risk-taking and so i said oh
no we do that and of course so every
single point you know he had an answer
as to why it wasn't true and i wasn't
again going to argue until we got to the
last one and this it's truth and go find
the last one was
europe doesn't listen to its young
and
[Applause]
he he looks at me and in all honesty
says why should we
you said something similar about that we
both
there's a lot of people who try to
imitate or have a sort of localized
wikipedia and they all fail
um i'm beginning to think that it's more
than just that there's
these things don't franchise because
they are only
really native to the place where they
grow
but that there's something about copying
that is remember xerox copies
were always unlike digital copies where
oz
not as good as the original not as good
as the original good couple copies out
and it's barely readable
and it feels like there's something like
that going on in and so the way
that long now we're trying to think
about this is
well there's some things that get better
when they're not authentic like greek
food
okay
and notice the difference the greeks
don't run what happens to greek food
what happens is that people elsewhere
steal the idea of greek food and then
improve on it so this is my theory of
franchising it doesn't work if there's
permission it only works if it's stolen
that's good that's nice
it's nice
oh i like that yeah that's good
now how do you encourage theft i guess
probably
probably by you know really fighting it
don't you dare steal this stuff yeah the
best way trademark put on trouble now
boy put a lock on it yeah
oh that's interesting
coming down to the final lap here bruce
miller asks how do self-educating
villages the future of national you know
the
dismal future of nationalism and 3d
printing come together in the long now
extrapolate a little farther here
um
how do they come together or
fan out
no nation's one language
uh
the one language might be more than a
hundred years but uh
a hundred years it's just when you
think back what's happened and you know
it's it's going faster and faster
um
[Music]
and exponentials are just always
mind-boggling and we seem to be on so
many exponentials so are you going to
put singularity blindness in this
conversation now yeah i'm sorry about
that the event horizon we can't think
beyond the event horizon it's only 20
years off so yeah i know it's it's not
20 but
you know i have hard time going beyond
2000 yeah it's a little
it's
um where do they come together
i guess
when you can't tell that's probably when
they come together you can't tell the
difference
they blended yeah then they just well
you sort of said that you had those four
things you said these are all going to
be
in
aspects of one thing
yeah i think it's
i think that's probably you know the
answer is that you just
you won't notice you won't be able to
tell the difference okay so one more
trip back to the run-up that you took
um you've been right about so many
things
what have you
noticed and enjoyed being wrong about
and the second part of that question is
what have you hated being wrong about
wow what interesting
what interesting questions um
i was
really wrong
about
how fast
speech would arrive that we would i just
even wrote about the fact we would all
we'd all be talking to things because
they were too small to deal with
otherwise and there would be i just
imagined a lot more of it and it's only
starting to happen pretty recently so i
i
i was always fond of telling people that
i'm always right
i just get the timing wrong right
yeah i got the timing so wrong in that
case that i might as well have been
wrong well this is the you know sappho's
mistaking
a clear view for a short distance yeah
um
what am i annoyed about
being wrong
it's interesting
i might have to think about that longer
than i want
because the things that i look back
for example as recently as one laptop
per child
i probably shouldn't have done battle
with intel
and i look back at that and think that
that was probably a mistake and it
annoys me because i remember
i remember the actual evening that had
happened and i was so pissed off and you
shouldn't be pissed off um
so that's
annoyed me sort of is that something
that
but that's not a prediction of fighting
rather than just going around or what
it's it's
because you do something because you
think it's a principle
and you're not
you
realize that the gratification you get
in being principled
actually screws a lot of other people
and
that's probably
the most frustrating kind of thing so
this must be a downside to the
non-profit mission oriented
um
yeah it certainly could be a downside
and
and again the the the mission versus
market is
is
you couldn't use them either way yeah
downside bigger downside to a business i
mean i've seen a lot of people who have
screwed up their own businesses by being
stubborn or
you know and then they go away the the
the
seeming advantage of nonprofits versus
businesses and i'm non-profit most of my
life and ryan is mostly business and we
this is a conversation in the family
but
a
a business goes out of business when it
screws up or or is unlucky
a non-profit has a harder time knowing
when
things aren't going right
because it's all song and dance anyway
and you know you can just keep
playing your music and yeah
nobody's dancing but it doesn't matter
well
is there i had this it doesn't matter
they don't do any harm
well it's again it
um
let me invert it and and talk
a little bit about
profits and this yeah profit making
startups in particular
um
because joey ito and i argue a little
bit about that and i say you know all
these startups
are sucking the people out of big
thinking
that
you get so many minds that used to
think
big
are now thinking small because they're
doing these
startups and their venture
funding
tells them and this is god i hate the
word
focus
you know focus
and
become cash flow positive which is a
really stupid idea and uh startup
it's truly stupid if you have a startup
you don't want to be cash flow positive
you want to come to a precipice and get
more you know build up the value keep
keep the risk high
so
i was just at
dinner with this modern meadows guy
um which one it was the i forget his
name now blocking his name but the
the young man who's the uh
ceo of it and
vinod kushler was sitting beside him and
i was sitting beside vinod and vinod was
giving him advice
on
how to start modern meadows
and i listened to the node
all the thing very
carefully listened and i finally said
you know vanode
every single thing you have just told
them
is the exact opposite of what i would
have told them
good okay exact opposite examples
examples do leather before meat right
become cash flow positive get rid of
your risk you know so
say huh you know why would you do that
don't don't screw around with leather do
meat and do meat fast and feed the world
and keep the risk high and you know get
as much money in as fast as possible in
other words
and i'm not saying
my advice would have been was
the exact opposite and
i don't know okay maybe i'm just i
think that the startup mentality
and there's some
extraordinary uh exceptions
uh a startup which i think is a big
exception is kickstarter i thought wow
that's actually a big idea and was done
rather well in the startup mode sort of
a meta startup yeah it was it was pretty
pretty extraordinary and
you know i
i like that when when you can find it
but it's not it's not it's pretty rare
so it sounds like you're not saying i
mean
vanilla is saying focus
start with leather and it's easy and
nobody complains about it so i can sort
of hear his arguments in fact i think
i've made a version of them
and you're saying something different
you're not saying blur
that's the opposite of focus
uh
[Music]
you're saying
be more insanely ambitious
yeah okay that's the opposite of focus
yes
yeah
go large
early go go weird early go
go to the strangest aspect of what
you're attempting
early rather than holding that for some
kind of once you've made all the money
then you get to be strange what are you
saying
um
now what i'm saying is
uh
be bold
versus timid
um
and
as far as you can
you know
if you if if you really say well they
these
really two
important markets and options and
somebody say well pick one
maybe not maybe you do two
maybe you do three in other words don't
focus as such is is not always a virtue
so it's not blur
um
it's more about boldness and
famously startups and
vcs and all that uh long now short now
they drive for a very short now get big
fast
uh you know niche niche niche in the
market
uh there's a there's a
going for
um
something tiny and masterable
in in very rapid fashion
is part of your worry that people who
[Music]
act that way will wind up
being only able to act that way and not
think large and long and deep
and strange
um
if i guess what i'm
saying is that if you
look at the world energy that's coming
from
maybe you can
think of it demographically
however you want to think about it
um
the number of people
that
in some sense did what you and i did and
we did it in different ways but we sort
of did the same thing
and
that's
happening less and less because there's
a lot of errors being sucked
into the world of startups and the world
of so-called entrepreneurship
and
innovation in ways that
ignore the fact that market forces don't
do everything
and
this is totally against the stream and
i'm not suggesting for a moment that
this is we should all revert to
government-funded research and
everybody be part of a university at all
but there is a smallness of thinking
that has evolved
that i just hadn't seen before just
generally
the thing that impresses me about google
is is that it is you know grad school at
stanford
writ large
and that they still work that way and
live that way and it is it is absolutely
a university it's it's byproduct
it's
it's extraordinary but it's
first of all it's a wild exception
and it's
got
two people who are
deep down techies and
it's kept its character
um
because of that
i don't see facebook doing that
well it's undergraduate not graduate
school
that's pretty good that's a good line
thank you for coming
it's very good
[Music]
you